pero veamos el siguiente gráfico el
banco mundial sustenta sus datos en el
impacto causado por las nuevas amenazas
derivadas de las variantes de kobe 19 el
aumento a la inflación la deuda y la
desigualdad de ingresos tras un
crecimiento de 5.5 en 2021 la economía
global caerá al 4,1 y al 3,2 en 2022 y
2023 respectivamente al tiempo que de
américa latina la situación se agrava
pues tras una recuperación del 67 en
2021 caerá a 26 y 27 respectivamente
cuáles son los factores que hacen que el
crecimiento sea particularmente bajo en
américa latina' que puede hacerse para
para minimizar los impactos
bueno primeramente hay que mirar a esta
interpretación con cuidado es verdad que
se va a desacelerar pero yo lo que diría
es que el año 2021 lo que hizo fue
sacarnos del pozo porque había caído
muchísimo la producción en américa
latina en eeuu en el mundo en general
por el hobby
el crecimiento del año desde el año 21
fue inusual y sin embargo ahora nos
encontramos con serios problemas que son
los problemas de las líneas de
suministro el hecho de que se acabó la
capacidad de darle digamos más incentivo
de la economía en la parte fiscal y el
hecho de que no se ha invertido tanto en
los últimos dos años todo eso nos va a
llevar a serios problemas en la parte de
desigualdad es un tema separado pero muy
muy serio y por qué digo que es muy
serio porque se ha agravado en el último
en los últimos dos años aunque ya venía
poniéndose bastante problemático en años
anteriores así que hay mucho que
trabajar hay muchos problemas está el
problema de educación el problema de
capital etcétera y eso todos tenemos que
ver cómo se puede trabajar en forma
cuidadosa paralela señor láser por su
parte entre los riesgos que destaca el
foro económico mundial se encuentra el
tema climático así como la presencia de
enfermedades infecciosas la pandemia ha
desviado la atención de los gobiernos
con respecto a la lucha climática cómo
retomar este camino en medio de una
crisis sanitaria que no ha terminado por
ejemplo y por supuesto nuestra capacidad
humana es de mirar las crisis inmediatas
y no las crisis que van a desarrollarse
en 10 años yo creo que la crisis de la
pandemia
espero que vaya a reducirse y que
podamos empezar a normalizar nuestra
situación en ese sentido y que estemos
preparados y ahí vamos a empezar a mirar
nuevamente el tema climático el tema
climático en realidad es mucho más grave
y mucho más perdurable que el tema de
salud y yo creo que fundamentalmente a
nivel político a nivel académico a nivel
de las instituciones
tenemos que apretar muy fuertemente para
que los políticos y las entidades que
tienen decisión en esto tomen acciones
fuertes en la parte climática
aunque parezca que no nos va a tocar en
el próximo en los próximos días o los
próximos meses